i have a voicemail number that number is
2192 davidp
i asked on the show yesterday if you are
a non-right winger
and you have a my pillow pillow please
let me know like the pillow can't
possibly be that good right
it seems to me that if you buy a my
pillow pillow it's political
i got a couple of voicemails about it
take a listen to this first one
hey my pillows is a good pillow period
no matter what he thinks
and also it's pretty slicky you put an
advertisement on this at the end of the
thing
right pretty sick of you kind of thing
but
my pillows is a good pillow period
this is how we're calling from the great
state of texas all right so howard from
texas likes the pilla
uh here's one other one who says i have
a pillow it's actually not that great
hi david this is jack from new jersey
and recently i'm going to show you put
out a call to uh members of your
audience
yes who are on the left who own a my
pillow
and let me tell you i'm as left as they
come and i don't own just
one my pillow but i own two my pillows
yeah uh i'm here live in my bed right
now
with both my pillows uh giving them a
test run
and if i may say they're they're just
pillows
uh i don't remember when i got that i
don't even
remember where i got them but i have
them uh
they're not as good as the tempur-pedic
pillows i have they're kind of a base
pillow
okay i wouldn't recommend they're just a
toilet
thanks dude just a pillow just a pillow
not exactly a ringing endorsement all
right so that there is
i'm actually surprised at the number of
people in the audience that have these
pillows
we have a great bonus show for you today
kim potter
the officer who killed dante wright has
been charged with
second degree manslaughter okay we will
talk about that on today's bonus show
democrats are now pushing for republican
support
on asian american hate crimes
legislation
will they get it unclear and
the biden administration is pushing for
a major
expansion of offshore wind energy
you are starting to see republicans say
oh but it doesn't look
good to look offshore off of our
beautiful
beaches and water you know into the into
the waterways and seeing
um wind turbines that is now what they
are saying
so we will talk about that this is a
great push it would be great to expand
that all of those stories
and more and i will be joined by
producer pat on today's bonus show
get instant access by signing up at
joinpakman.com
i'll see you then